well if you want details we have them
about the Big Bang Theory's new spinoff
series it's going to revolve around Jim
Parsons character and we are unlocking
the mysteries of this new universe with
the six degrees of young Sheldon I don't
care how damn witted you are scientific
principles have to make you smile Jim
Parsons is an executive producer and the
narrator of the series about how his
character Sheldon from the Big Bang
Theory became a nerdy super genius young
Sheldon is already in high school at the
age of nine he's played by in Armitage
there's something about Ian that just
popped immediately you may recognize him
as shailene woodley son Ziggy on the HBO
hit big little lies Jim and Ian are
already bonding in fact two weeks ago
they took in a Broadway musical together
what advice did Jim Parsons give you it
would range from stuff like say this
little differently a shovel think of it
differently Groot he would say don't
smile yeah like an um like some of the
lines like I'm an but smile I know you
want to smile and I haven't be nice to
people don't don't do that anymore you
have a bit of a mustache Sheldon
Cooper's mom Mary on the Big Bang Theory
is played by Laurie Metcalf her
real-life daughter is scandal Zooey
Perry and she's playing young Sheldon's
mom on the new series and the
resemblance is striking
are there any mannerisms that you're
taking directly from your mom not
willingly not not thought out
I think genetics does that for me well I
referred to her as Laurie so many times
during the shoot I'm surprised she still
speaks to me anymore high school is a
haven for higher learning no dear God
and the new gig came just a time for Zoe
spoiler alert she was just killed off a
scandal
you